OUT OF HIS OPPONENT’S UNDER
BOOK.
RAYMOND ARROYO IS HERE WITH A
SPECIAL SEEN AND UNSEEN.
NEWS IS MOVING FAST ON THE
CORONAVIRUS FRONT.
YOU HEARD SOME OF IT EARLIER
TODAY, BUT EVEN TONIGHT THINGS
ARE CHANGING.
THE GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO IT,
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
LATEST.
NOW WE HAVE THIS
2.1-$2.2 TRILLION RELIEF PACKAGE
THAT BOTH PARTIES IT SEEMS LIKE
FINALLY AGREED ON TODAY.
>> THIS $2.2 TRILLION
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IS BIGGER
THAN ANYTHING I BELIEVE EVER
PASSED IN CONGRESS.
PERHAPS RELATIVELY SPEAKING IF
YOU GO BACK, LOOK DURING THE FDR
NEW DEAL DAYS THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT IF YOU TIME
VALUATE YOU COULD SAY IT WAS
BIGGER I DON’T KNOW, BUT THIS IS
CERTAINLY, IN TERMS OF DOLLARS,
BY FAR AND AWAY THE BIGGEST
EVER -- EVER DONE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THAT HAS
SENT A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES
GASPING WHEN THEY HEARD THAT BUT
WE KNOW WHAT WAS COMING AND MOST
OF US DID UNDERSTAND IT.
SOMETHING NEEDED TO BE DONE TO
HELP AMERICAN WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES.
THERE’S A LOT AT THE SAME TIME
NOT TO LIKE IN THIS PACKAGE.
CHECK THIS OUT, NANCY PELOSI IS
STILL HOLDING OUT FOR THIS
PROVISION THAT WOULD BASICALLY
GOT ANY STATE VOTER I.D.
REQUIREMENTS.
I KID YOU NOT.
AND THERE’S ALL SORT OF STUFF
WITH THE BALLOT HARVESTING.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE.
THINKING ABOUT THIS, I GUESS
THEY’RE WATCHING OLD JOE ’S
CAMPAIGN STUMBLES -- THE WHOLE
THING IS REALLY STARTING TO LOOK
LIKE A WEEKEND AT BIDEN’S, AS I
SAID A FEW WEEKS AGO.
AT ANOTHER CONCERN WITH THE
FEDERAL UNAPPOINTED BENEFITS,
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO GET HELP,
BUT WILL LAST 39 WEEKS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THROUGH THE END
OF 2020, GOD HELP US IF THIS
SHUTDOWN GOES ON THAT LONG OR
ANYWHERE APPROACHING THAT LONG.
SO WHEN YOU ADD UP THE STATE ON
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WITH THE
FEDERAL BENEFITS, THE AVERAGE
WEEKLY UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK WILL
BE ABOUT $972 WHICH AGAIN, WHEN
YOU DO THE MATH, IT SEEMS THE
MEDIAN WEEKLY EARNINGS OF
AMERICAN WORKERS FROM QUARTER
FOUR OF LAST YEAR.
MEANWHILE, THE DIRE TONE SEEMED
TO CHANGE TODAY AT THE NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ’S COVID-19 BRIEFING.
CUOMO SEEMED TO LET UP A LITTLE
BIT ON THE BLAME GAME.
>> IT’S SOMETHING THAT OUR TEAM
IS WORKING ON THE WHITE HOUSE
TEAM AND I WANT TO THANK THE
PRESIDENT FOR HIS COOPERATION
AND HIS TEAM FOR THEIR
COOPERATION.
>> Laura: THAT WAS GOOD TO
HEAR.
AND EVEN AS NEW YORK STILL
ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 60% OF NEW
COVID CASES, THERE IS MORE ROOM
FOR OPTIMISM.
IT ACTUALLY APPEARS THAT THE
RATE OF HOSPITALIZATIONS IS
SLOWING.
REMEMBER, THE BIG CONCERN ALWAYS
HAS BEEN A POTENTIAL COLLAPSE OF
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
>> THIS PAST SUNDAY BUT
PROJECTION WAS BUT
HOSPITALIZATIONS WERE DOUBLING
EVERY TWO DAYS.
OKAY?
ON MONDAY, THE NUMBERS SUGGEST
THAT THE HOSPITALIZATIONS WERE
DOUBLING EVERY 3.4 DAYS.
ON TUESDAY, THE PROJECTIONS
SUGGEST OF THE HOSPITALIZATIONS
WERE DOUBLING EVERY 4.7 DAYS.
NOW, THAT IS ALMOST TOO GOOD TO
BE TRUE.
THE ARROWS ARE HEADED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND THAT IS
ALWAYS BETTER THAN THE ARROWS
HEADED IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> Laura: I’LL SAY.
AND THE NUMBER OF NEW INFECTIONS
IN NEW YORK IS STARTING TO SHOW
SOME SIGNS OF GOOD NEWS AS WELL.
ON MONDAY THE STATE REPORTED AN
INCREASE OF 5,707.
ON TUESDAY IT WENT UP 4,790,
THAT’S NEARLY 1,000 PERSON
DECREASE IN THE RATE OF
INCREASE, THAT KIND OF GETS
CONFUSING BUT TODAY IT WENT UP
5,146, BUT THAT IS STILL DOWN
TWO DAYS AGO.
YOU SEE THOSE TRENDS.
IF THAT TREND DOES HOLD, IT’S
REALLY GOOD NEWS ABOUT WHEN THIS
NIGHTMARE ACTUALLY PEAKS AND
THEN WE START SEEING LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
BUT FEAR IS POWERFUL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT END IN THIS
CASE IT’S UNDERSTANDABLE, GIVEN
WHAT WE’VE SEEN.
AROUND THE WORLD, ESPECIALLY IN
PLACES LIKE ITALY.
BUT FEAR ALONE SHOULD NOT DRIVE
POLICY.
FACTS AND RELIABLE UPDATED DATA
SHOULD INFORM ALL OF OUR
PROJECTIONS.
DR. BIRX FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE SEEMED TO BE ALLUDING
TO THAT TODAY.
>> WE’RE DEALING WITH THE HERE
AND NOW, WHILE WE ARE PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE, AND I THINK THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
OUT THERE ARE ACTUALLY VERY
FRIGHTENING TO PEOPLE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IF YOU GO
BACK AND LOOK AT WUHAN AND ALL
OF THESE PROVINCES, WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT 60,000 PEOPLE BEING
INFECTED, EVEN IF YOU SAID
ALL RIGHT, WHILE THERE IS A
SYMPTOMATICS AND OF THAT, 60,000
PEOPLE OUT OF 80 MILLION.
THAT IS NOWHERE CLOSE TO THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU SEE PEOPLE
PUTTING OUT THERE.
I THINK IT HAS FRIGHTENED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THAT’S PERSPECTIVE,
WE NEED THAT PERSPECTIVE.
AS SCARY AS THIS SEEMS.
FINALLY, NEW DRUG THERAPIES ARE
BEING TESTED AND USED INCLUDING
ONE USED EVEN TO TREAT GOUT AND
ANYBODY’S TEST -- ANTIBODIES
TEST MAY TELL US WHO ALREADY HAS
IMMUNITIES AND IS VIRUS, MAY
HAVE GOTTEN IT, NOT HAD A STRONG
REACTION TO IT, ALREADY
DEVELOPING THOSE IMPORTANT
COMMUNITIES, THAT WILL ALSO HELP
US PREPARE BETTER FOR THE FUTURE
FUTURE.
AND AROUND THE WORLD COUNTRIES
ARE TAKING DIFFERENT APPROACHES.
INDIA HAS A TOTAL LOCKDOWN NOW
AND AFTER ITALY’S HORRIFIC
EXPERIENCE, YOU KIND OF CAN’T
BLAME PEOPLE, EXTREME SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
IT’S AFFECTED IN THE U.K., AND
SPAIN.
BUT SWEDEN AND DENMARK HAVE
REJECTED THE TOTAL LOCKDOWN
APPROACH AND ARE GETTING SOME
GRIEF FOR IT, BUT ARE NOT SEEING
A GREATER RATE OF INFECTION THAN
SOME OF THEIR EUROPEAN
COUNTERPARTS, THAT’S REALLY
INTERESTING.
ONLY TIME WILL TELL WHICH
APPROACH WAS RIGHT AND WHICH ONE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN GOING A LITTLE
TOO EXTREME.
BUT FOR US, WE ARE ENDING DAY
TEN OF THE FIRST 15 DAYS AND HOW